[Music]
described as
powerful and noble
which way
[Music]
now seen as tasteless and shameful by
critics of johnny depp
i can feel it he's still the face of
sauvage by dior
that's despite the high court ruling
he'd assaulted his ex-wife
amber heard we should not underestimate
what abuse does to a person domestic
abuse survivors like jennifer say such a
big
brand continuing with mr depp could keep
people in abusive relationships
it could be finance it could be and
they've got
children it's the fear there's there's
so many reasons as to why
somebody doesn't leave having something
in the papers like that
and having that media on there and that
it's been you know he's still being
promoted
and having that work could just be that
other reason
for somebody not to leave the old ways
serve us no longer johnny depp was
forced to quit fantastic beasts
after losing his libel trial against the
sun newspaper
for an article describing him as a wife
beater he denies the allegations and has
appealed
but some domestic abuse charities want
the public to avoid buying dior
we need big powerful rich organizations
to take domestic abuse seriously to take
a stand
to stand by so many women who've had
domestic abuse experience and are still
living with those experiences
and to act differently and to make a
change
the actor's suing amber heard personally
but his reputation
and brand depth has taken a hit dior
ultimately seems to have taken the view
that all publicity is at some level good
publicity i think that seeking to imbue
your brands
with an edgy quality by virtue of an
association with someone that
a uk judge has deemed to have been an
abuser
may not turn out to have been a very
wise move
[Music]
there's some suggestion sales of the
cologne have risen
sky news has contacted dior for comment
meanwhile off-screen as legal battles
continue in the u.s
the publicity and controversy
surrounding this hollywood couple
is yet to fade adele robinson sky news